>> AND NOW, GOING TO CHARLESTON
WHERE THE COMMUNITY IS WAITING,
AND WE HAVE MIGUEL MARQUEZ THERE,
AND THE HIGH TIDE JUST AS THE
HURRICANE IS SET TO COME ASHORE,
AND WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> YEAH, IT IS PRETTY MISERABLE
RIGHT NOW, AND THIS IS THE WORST
THAT WE HAVE SEEN.
THE WINDS ARE REALLY STARTING TO
DUST UP, AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
RAIN COMING IN, AND PUSHED BY
THE WIND.
WHEN IT IS STARTS TO HURT YOUR
FACE AND FEEL IT THROUGH THE
CLOTHING, YOU KNOW IT IS BAD.
THIS IS WHAT SOME OF THE BAY IS
LOOKING LIKE, AND THE TIDE IS
NOT EXPECTED TO BE AS HIGH AS
THEY THOUGHT EARLIER.
IT IS FORECAST TO BE OVER 9 FEET
TODAY, BUT THEY ARE BELIEVING IT
IS GOING TO BE 7 1/2 FEET.
ONE BIT FOR CHARLESTON, IT IS
LOOKING LIKE THE STORM IS GOING
TO PASS TO THE EAST, AND IT IS
GOING TO PUSH IT OUT MORE INTO
THE OCEAN, SO THIS STREET IS
BLOCKED OUT HERE, AND SOME FOLKS
ARE OUT AND ABOUT, AND THIS IS
NOT A TERRIBLE STORM FOR CH
CHARLESTON SO FAR, AND THERE IS
POWER OUT TO SOME PEOPLE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS, BUT IT IS LOW
COUNTRY, SO THEY ARE USED TO IT.
THEY ARE NOT EXPECTING ANYTHING
CERTAINLY AS BAD AS FLORIDA HAS
SEEN, BUT THEY ARE ON ALERT.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS SOME OF THE
WORST OF IT.
THEY ARE EXPECTING THAT THEY MAY
SEE SOME FLOODING IN THIS AREA,
AND OTHER PARTS OF CHARLESTON,
BUT RIGHT NOW, EVERYTHING IS IN
PLACE TO DEAL WITH THIS STORM.
CLEARLY THE WIND IS PICKING UP
RIGHT NOW, AND THEY ARE GOING TO
WAIT IT OUT.
THEY ARE ASKING PEOPLE TO STAY
HOME, AND ENJOY THE DAY IN THE
WARMTH OF YOUR OWN HOME.
>> AND MIGUEL, IF YOU CAN HEAR
ME, AND IF FOR ANY REASON THAT
YOU NEED TO GO, PLEASE DO SO,
AND CHARLESTON IS USED TO
ROUTINE FLOODING AFTER HEAVY
RAIN, AND IF FOR SOME REASON
COMPLACENCY SETS IN AND WE WILL
RIDE IT OUT LIKE THE LAST ONE,
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE?
>> IT IS ALWAYS A FEAR, BUT
BECAUSE OF HOW HARD THIS STORM
HIT FLORIDA, PEOPLE ARE ON A
HIGHER ALERT.
THEY HAVE BEEN WATCHING FOR MUCH
OF THE DAY.
THIS IS THE WORST OF WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN THIS STORM SO FAR.
WE DO SEE A FEW PEOPLE COMING
DOWN HERE TO SORT OF LOOK
AROUND.
BUT THE WATER HAS NOT COME UP
NEARLY AS QUICKLY AS THEY
THOUGHT IT WOULD, AND SO FAR,
CHARLESTON SEEMS TO BE DOING
OKAY, BUT WE SEEM TO BE IN THE
WORST OF THE STORM THAT
CHORCHORLZ
T
-- CHARLESTON IS GOING TO BE
SEEING.
>> AND THANK YOU, MIGUEL
MARQUEZ.
AND WE HAVE CHAD MYERS STANDING
BY, AND YOU HAVE SEEN MIGUEL
MARQUEZ THERE, AND YOU HAVE BEEN
THROUGH IT TIME AFTER TIME AFTER
TIME, AND HE IS TALKING ABOUT
THE RAIN COMING IN SIDEWAYS.
WHERE IS HE IN TERMS OF THE
ENCOUNTER WITH IAN?
>> HE IS JUST TO THE WEST OF IAN
WHICH IS LIKELY SAVED DAMAGES IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
CHARLESTON, BECAUSE THE 5:00
A.M. FORECAST WAS FOR THE SURGE,
THE TIDE TO GET TO 9 FEET.
CHARLESTON IS FLOODING AT 6 1/2,
AND SO YES, WE WILL FLOOD AT A
FOOT, BUT NOT 2 1/2 FEET INTO
ALL OF THE HOMES REALLY IN THE
DOWNTOWN.
SOME SANDBAGS CAN TAKE CARE OF
THAT.
IT IS STILL AN 85-MILE-AN-HOUR
STORM, AP IT IS STILL GOING TO
BE MOVING IN SHORE OF THE LOW
COUNTRY OF SOUTH CAROLINA AND
LIKELY CLOSE TO GEORGETOWN AND
BIG CITY AND BIG TOWN RIGHT
THERE ALONG THE MARSHES THOUGH,
SO AS THE RAIN IS CONTINUING TO
COME IN AND PUSHES THE WATER IN,
AND I HAVE BEEN LOOKIING AT THE
MERLES ISLANDS, AND THE GOATS
ARE APPARENTLY NOT AS HARD TO
EVACUATE AS PEOPLE.
THEY GOT RIGHT IN.
AND SO, SOME OF THIS IS GOING TO
BE FLOODING FOR 4 TO 6 INCHES OF
RAIN AND PUT DOWN 2 TO 3 FEET
WORTH OF SURGE IN PARTS OF NORTH
CAROLINA, AND THAT IS SOMETHING
TO BE CONCERNED WITH.
AND THE WINDS WILL GUST INTO
HURRICANE STRENGTH FROM MYRTLE
BEACH TO GARDEN CITY ALL OF THE
WAY TO CHERRY GROVE.
HERE IS THE WINDFIELD BLOWING
AGAIN, AND IT IS GOING TO BE
BLOWING INTO THE CAROLINAS AND
GET THE TREES DOWN INTO VIRGINIA
FOR SURE LIKELY, AND BELIEVE IT
OR NOT, JOHN, THIS IS GOING TO
START TO RAIN IN NEW YORK CITY
TOMORROW MORNING, AND IT IS
GOING TO BE ALL OF THE WAY NORTH
HERE.
THIS IS THE LATEST FORECAST BY
THE RADAR MOVING UP FROM RALEIGH
TO SHORT, AND WHEN THE CELLS GET
HERE, THERE IS WIND 40 TO 50
MILES PER HOUR FROM NORTH
CAROLINA, VIRGINIA AND POSSIBLY
UP TO INTO, MARYLAND, VIRGINIA,
DELMARVA AND WITH THE BIGGER
CELLS THE WIND WILL COME IN.
AND ANOTHER THING TO SHOW YOU,
EARTH CAM FROM MYRTLE BEACH.
EARLIER, THE TIDE IS WAY OUT
HERE, AND NOW WITH THE HIGH TIDE
AND THE SURGE RIGHT UP TO THE
MARSH AND I HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
THE PICTURES COMING IN FROM SURF
SIDE, AND COMING IN FROM GARDEN
CITY, THE WATER IN THE STREETS
RIGHT NOW, OVER THE TOP OF THE
DUNES, BECAUSE THE DUNES DOWN
THERE IN THE LOWER PART OF THE
LOW COUNTRY OF THE GRAND STRAND
A LOT LOWER DOWN THERE, AND THE
WATER IS OVER THE TOP OF SOME OF
THOSE DUNES.
>> CHAD, A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE,
AND LET ME ASK YOU, WHEN IT HIT
SOUTHWESTERN FLORIDA, AND WE
HAVE ALL OF THE HEAVY DAMAGE OF
SANIBEL, AND YOU HAVE THE
DIFFERENT COAST, THE JAGGED
COAST OF THE ATLANTIC, AND NOW
ON THE OTHER SIDE, AND IT HAS
CROSSED THE FLORIDA PENINSULA,
BUT YOU HAVE MORRIS ISLAND TO
THE SOUTH, AND THE ISLAND OF
PALMS GOING UP, AND THE INLETS
AND THE RIVERS AND HOW DOES IT
COMPLICATE THINGS?
DOES THAT AREA HELP TO PROTECT
THE COAST OR DOES THE WATER
RESUPPLY POTENTIALLY DAMAGING TO
THE COAST?
>> DUE TO THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
BUILD ALONG THE INTERCOASTAL,
WATER IS COMING IN FROM THE
OTHER SIDE, AND SO, YES, IT DOES
HELP
HELP, BUT YOU HAVE TO STAY AWAY
AND AS THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
LIVE BY THE WATER, NOT BUILD SO
CLOSE.
>> THANK YOU, CHAD.
WE WILL KEEP YOU CLOSE
THROUGHOUT THE NEXT FEW HOURS
AND THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
>>> AND AS SOUTH CAROLINA IS
WAITING, FLORIDA IS SUFFERING.
OUR JOHN BERMAN TOOK TOUR IN
PLACES WHERE BUSINESSES STOOD
JUST DAYS AGO.
>> ALL OF THE DEBRIS IS LITTERED
EVERYWHERE.
THIS WERE BUILDINGS RIGHT THERE?
>> THERE WERE BUILDINGS,
RESTAURANTS AND WHAT USED TO BE
THE FORT MYERS PIER.
THE EMPTY SPOTS THERE WERE
HOMES.
>> I AM SORRY, SO THESE, THESE
ON THIS BEACH HERE, THIS WERE
HOMES?
>> THESE EMPTY LOTS, RIGHT
THERE, THOSE LOTS WERE HOMES.
THOSE WERE HOTELS, AND THOSE
WERE REAL PROPERTY, TWO, THREE,
FOUR OR FIVE-STORIES HIGH WASHED
AWAY.
>> RANDI KAYE IS THERE IN FORT
MYERS, FLORIDA, AND RANDI, IT IS
DEVASTATING TO SEE JOHN BERMAN'S
VIEW FROM ABOVE, AND YOU ARE AT
THE GROUND LEVEL AND SEEING MORE
OF IT.
>> YES, WE CERTAINLY ARE, JOHN.
WE ARE AT FORT MYERS BEACH AND
JUST BEHIND ME, YOU ARE SEEING
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN ALONG THE WAY,
AND CAPTAIN TONY'S FISHING
ADVENTURES IS A POPULAR TOURISM
BOAT, AND MEANWHILE, IT IS ON
GROUND, AND PUSHED OUT OF THE
GULF AND ON TO DRYLAND.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE IS
ANOTHER BOAT BEHIND IT, THE
SMALLER BOAT, AND THE TRAILER,
AND THE SMALLER BOAT WAS ON THE
TRAILER, AND ALL OF IT WAS
PUSHED ON TO DRY LAND, AND THEN
THERE'S A COUPLE OF OTHER BOATS
BEHIND THERE, AND BOTH OF THEM
ARE 50 TONS, ACTUALLY.
WE SPOKE TO THE OWNER, AND THIS
IS HIS BUSINESS AND IT WAS LIKE
A FLOATING HOTEL, AND HE
ACTUALLY RODE THE STORM OUT ON
ONE OF THE BOATS WHICH NOW HAS A
GIANT HOLE IN IT, AND HE WAS ON
IT AS HE WAS CARRIED TO DRYLAND,
AND WE SPOKE TO HIM EARLIER.
>> IT WAS WINDY AND A LOT OF
RAIN OBVIOUSLY.
IT WASN'T JUST -- WE HELD OUR
OWN FOR A LONG TIME UNTIL ABOUT
3:00 OR SO, AND WE KEPT THE BOAT
IN THE SLIP WITH THE ENGINES AND
THEN THE TIDE CAME HIGH EAR AND
THE WINDS REALLY RAMPED UP, AND
THE BOAT RELEASE AND WE CRUISED
ACROSS THE PARKING LOT.
>> HE SAID IT WAS INCREDIBLE,
AND HE WAS NOT THAT SCARED
BECAUSE THE BOAT WAS MADE OF
STEEL, AND HE DIDN'T FEEL THAT
THE STORM WOULD THAT BE BAD, BUT
HE SAW THE BUILDINGS COLLAPSE
INTO THE WATER, AND OTHERS THAT
HAD BEEN IN DRY LAND.
AND THIS IS ALSO WHAT WE ARE
FINDING A MARINA THAT IS NOW
SHATTERED AND RESTAURANTS THAT
ARE SHATTERED.
WE SAW BOATS THAT ARE BASICALLY
THAT HAVE BEEN TOSSED AROUND
LIKE TOYS IN THE TREES AND ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
THERE IS A BUNCH OF TWISTED
METAL AND BOATS DOWN THERE, AND
WE ARE NOT FAR FROM THE GULF.
IF WE WENT THIS WAY, WE WOULD GO
RIGHT ON TO THE ACTUAL BEACH OF
FORT MYERS WHICH JOHN BERMAN WAS
FLYING OVER.
THERE IS SO MUCH DESTRUCTION AND
SO MUCH DEBRIS IN THE ROAD THAT
THEY ARE TURNING PEOPLE BACK,
JOHN.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
SOMEBODY IN HIS STORY TO TELL
THAT WE ARE SEEING ALONG THE WAY
HERE IN FORT MYERS BEACH.
>> BEFORE I LET YOU GO, RANDI, I
WILL WANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE OF YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND GOING OUT TO
BARRIER ISLAND AND THE CAUSEWAY
DESTROYED AND THE PICTURES
COMING IN, AND WHETHER IT IS
SANIBEL OR WHERE YOU ARE IN FORT
MYERS AND DAY ONE, DO WE NEED TO
FIND PEOPLE AND RESCUE PEOPLE,
AND THE DAY TWO IS WHOA, AS YOU
ARE LOOKING AT THE DEVASTATION
AND TRYING TO HAVE SOME CONTEXT
AND THEN YOU TRY TO ADD IT UP,
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE, AND HOW
MUCH DOES IT COST, AND WHEN CAN
I GO HOME IF MY HOUSE IS NO
LONGER THERE, AND WHAT DO YOU
SEE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS STEADY
STREAM OF TRAFFIC WHICH IS
PRETTY REMARKABLE, BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALL BEING TURNED AWAY WHEN
THEY GET TO THE BEACH.
SOME OF THEM ARE CURIOUS PEOPLE,
AND THEY WANT TO SEE SOME OF THE
DAMAGE, BUT SOME OF THEM ARE THE
HOMEOWNERS TO WANT TO GO SEE
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE HOMES
AND WHAT IS LEFT OF THEM
CERTAINLY AT FORT MYERS BEACH,
AND THE BOAT OWNER, AND THE
POWER COMPANY CAME BY, AND THE
POWER LINES ARE WHAT STOPPED HIS
BOAT FROM GOING FURTHER TO WHERE
WE ARE ACROSS THE STREET.
SO HE IS SITTING ON POWER LINES.
SO THERE IS SO MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE AND SO MANY QUESTIONS FROM
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT IS NEXT, JOHN.